[Música]
economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna me acompaña en el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge Bienvenido a directo a
América vamos a comenzar hablando de lo
que ha pasado con la economía del Reino
Unido Después de tres años de su retiro
de la Unión Europea episodio conocido
como El brexit Bueno en este tiempo la
queja principal es que los beneficios
que se prometieron respecto al brexit
Pues todavía no llega en 2020 el
entonces Primer Ministro por Johnson
prometió que se iba a desarrollar su
potencial económico pero hasta hoy
sucede todo lo contrario ya que varios
indicadores muestran un rendimiento
inferior al de otras economías por
ejemplo Reino Unido es la única economía
avanzada del grupo de los siete que aún
no se recupera el tamaño anterior que
tenía previo la pandemia la situación
actual se resume en una crisis por la
inflación anual más alta en 40 años
específicamente el 10,5% reportado en
diciembre de 2022 faltan también
trabajadores en muchos sectores como el
de salud y atención social y esto es
agra por huelgas de numerosos sectores
como los trabajadores ferroviarios los
enfermeros los empleados del servicio de
ambulancias maestros entre otros centros
de pensamientos y organismos
independientes revelan que esa economía
creció un 5,5% menos en 2022 por la
salida de la Unión Europea el 77% de las
empresas admiten que el brexit no les
ayudó a expandir su negocio como había
sido prometido y el 44% de las empresas
también reportan dificultades para los
visados del personal Jorge hablemos
ahora de un estudio de economía que
reporta que el centro y el este de
Europa que son economías mucho más
pequeñas que las del Reino Unido van a
crecer a pesar de tener la Guerra de
Ucrania a la vuelta de la esquina bueno
Santiago lo dice el instituto de Viena
para estudios económicos internacionales
según ellos la estrategia de Rusia de
usar la energía como un arma política
fracasó entre otros motivos porque los
países del centro este y sureste de
Europa lograron reducir su consumo de
gas el prevé que los países de la región
miembros de la Unión Europea
experimentarán un crecimiento económico
del 1% por encima del cero coma dos por
ciento previsto para el conjunto de toda
la Unión Europea el estudio también
muestra que los países del sureste
mostraron ser más resilientes mientras
que los del llamado grupo de
Belgrado Hungría Eslovaquia República
Checa y Polonia tendrán un crecimiento
medio del 0,6% Aunque la economía caerá
un 1%. eso sí advierten que el
pronóstico queda reservado a una
escalada de tensiones producto de la
guerra en Ucrania hablemos ahora de la
industria Automotriz porque las empresas
reinó que es francesa y Nissan japonesa
acordaron igualar sus participaciones y
también hacer un relanzamiento de su
Alianza histórica Así es un anuncio
bastante importante sobre todo en el en
el sector privado de los grupos
automotrices y el grupo francés reducirá
del 43% al 15%
en su socio japonés de forma que los dos
ahora tendrán la misma participación en
la otra compañía con el acuerdo Nissan
logró reequilibrar la relación comercial
y Renault consiguió más inversión en su
unidad de negocio de vehículos
eléctricos en el esquema actual con el
dominante de Renault sobre Nissan la
forma la firma japonesa no tenía derecho
de Voto en el grupo Francés pero ahora
las empresas se tratarán como iguales y
tendrán derecho de Voto equivalente a su
participación del 15%, el acuerdo se da
tras meses de tensas negociaciones que
estuvieron a punto de fracasar por los
puntos conflictivos en materia de
propiedad intelectual la alianza inicio
en 1999 cuando Renault rescató a Nissan
Con una inyección de liquidez y ambas
formaron una de las mayores asociaciones
automovilísticas del sector conocemos
ahora el Atlántico hablamos de América
Latina Porque mientras continúan las
manifestaciones ciudadanas en Perú Ya se
contabilizan las millonarias pérdidas
que dejan los bloqueos y los más
económicos en Perú la cifra ya alcanza
los quinientos millones de dólares por
estos bloqueos producto de las
manifestaciones de las regiones más
afectadas son las sureñas cusco madre de
Dios y puno que debido a los bloqueos en
las carreteras desde diciembre ya sufren
de desabastecimiento de combustible y
también el aumento de los precios en los
alimentos las pérdidas rondan los 554
millones de dólares eso según lo
confirmó esta semana el ministro de
economía Álex Contreras el funcionario
aseguró que si no se consigue un diálogo
entre las partes y el conflicto se
mantiene la economía peruana solo va a
crecer 2% en el primer trimestre de este
año pero si hay una reactivación gracias
al consenso político el alza del
producto interno bruto sería de al menos
el 3%, al menos un millón de puestos de
trabajo que equivalen al 27% del empleo
formal en Perú están en riesgo de
perderse dijeron por las protestas esto
según la cámara de comercio de Lima y la
cifra del día para el cierre 26 millones
de dólares al día envia los colombianos
en el exterior en 2022 los datos de las
remesas del Banco Central muestran que
el año pasado Colombia recibió remesas
por
9.428 millones de dólares una cifra
récord y un repunte de 800 millones de
dólares adicionales Comparado con la
cifra de 2021 se consolida como un ítem
importante en la economía colombiana
Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización a continuación en directo
América ya viene el debate
[Música]